it's only a heart attack if you have
chest pain uh-uh you can't die from a
broken heart can you die from a broken
heart the answer is yes
a keto diet is the best for your heart
this one you can see by my face really
really angers me i'm eugenia giannis a
professor of cardiology at the zuckers
school of medicine and director of
cardiovascular prevention at northwell
health my goal is to keep people from
having heart attacks from having strokes
hi i'm vanita shah i am an
interventional cardiologist at the nyu
grossman school of medicine i open up
blockages when people have heart attacks
and try to save their lives in the
moment and today we'll be debunking
myths about the heart red wine is good
for your heart well i love my red wine
so i'm going to give this one to you
i'm sorry to be the bearer of bad news
but we don't really encourage people to
start drinking to have better heart
health so one glass is okay right one
glass is fine a day there are good
things about red wine there is
reservatrol in red wine which can
decrease inflammation and help the
arteries relax however the negative
aspects there's calories in wine and
leads to weight gain and you get higher
blood pressure your heart can get
stretched and you may have more
irregular heart rhythms there could be
liver problems down the line up to one
glass a day of red wine could
potentially be good for your heart you
can't die from a broken heart i will
take that one not only have i had some
heartbreaks personally but unfortunately
i do end up treating a lot of patients
in the cath lab who do come in with what
we call broken heart syndrome the
medical term is really a stress-induced
cardiomyopathy what happens is that
there's an emotional stressor something
that allows a surge of catecholamines to
release from your body that's toxic to
your heart muscle and constricts down
the vessels around your body so that the
heart has to pump even harder to get the
blood flow out there and with all those
stresses the heart muscle definitely
starts to fail so can you die from a
broken heart the answer is yes luckily
if you make it to the hospital in time
and we're able to treat you the
likelihood of actually dying from it is
quite low at the end of the day broken
hearts are real and you have to manage
your stressors in life a keto diet is
the best for your heart this one you can
see by my face really really angers me i
can't tell you how much time i spend in
my practice debunking the myth that the
keto diet is good for you it's not a
sustainable diet it's not a long-term
thing yes it's really good for weight
loss because it's really low in carbs
and then your body ends up being
depleted of sugar so then it breaks down
fat but what are you eating if you're
not eating carbohydrates you're eating
more protein and a lot of fat most
people who do this diet do it in a
heavily animal based way when you eat
animal products in general there are
some direct components that are bad for
the heart something called
trimethylamine that gets converted in
the gut and that leads to heart disease
there's also saturated fat in your
animal products that is causing your
cholesterol to go really really high
you're also getting very little fiber
and fiber is what lowers your
cholesterol and you and i actually
worked together a few years ago looking
at this a little bit more closely what
we were sort of
looking for was to change animal-based
protein for plant-based protein and we
saw that with the
plant-based protein vegetables fruit
whole grains their cholesterols were
lower their inflammation levels were
lower so really it's that whole foods
plant-based diet that's probably better
than this keto diet eggs are bad for
your heart are they so when it comes to
eggs there's a lot of controversy eggs
are good in a lot of ways they have some
protein and b12 and folate and omega-3
fatty acids but they also do have a lot
of that cholesterol a little bit of
saturated fat and
animal products in general are
associated with more heart disease if
you're eating the eggs with cheese and
bacon on a white processed roll probably
not so great how about egg whites versus
yolks good question so if you're going
to have any component of the egg then
the egg white probably has the most
protein at least fat even that i would
say still keep in moderation but
definitely a better part of the egg
heart attacks don't happen to healthy
people not true heart attacks really can
happen to anyone so many people come to
me and say i exercise a ton i'm at the
gym all the time i'm in really good
shape
i should be fine right and i say well
unless you know your numbers you do not
know that you need to know what your
cholesterol looks like you need to know
what your blood sugars look like you
need to know what your blood pressure
look like because there is a genetic
component and then the other thing i
want to talk about is what defines
healthy skinny is not necessarily
healthy obesity is not necessarily
unhealthy what is going on in your
bloodstream in your arteries in your
entire body with your organs that's
really the marker of your true health
all fats are unhealthy i think i
probably thought this was the case when
i was in college and i lived on things
like frozen yogurt and pasta and
pretzels but
all fats are not bad good fats
monounsaturated polyunsaturated fats in
nuts and in avocados and in healthy fish
such as salmon cod mackerel herring but
the bad fats definitely to be avoided
are the saturated ones and what we call
trans fats because trans fats are
actually fats that are created
synthetically and our bodies can't break
them down when you exchange good fats
for bad fats in your diet your heart
disease risk goes down so why is that
one it does actually lower your
cholesterol to some extent two it causes
your arteries to relax better and they
help plaque in the arteries heal so my
hand full of almonds and my handful of
walnuts those are good choices i'm
making those are great so
limit
saturated fats eliminate trans fats and
get more good fats in your diet it's
only a heart attack if you have chest
pain
no way why not do you know how many
people come to me and i say oh did you
have chest pain and the patient's like
no no chest pain and i say well did you
have any pressure in your chest any
discomfort in your chest and your
shoulder and your arm and your jaw and
they're like oh yeah i had all of that
like an elephant sitting on my chest
some people will also have symptoms of
just feeling the sudden nausea or
wanting to vomit a bunch of hiccups
along the way there are a few cases of
what we call silent heart attacks i
think in actuality it's usually not
silent it was usually just a symptom
that somebody missed along the way if
you feel suddenly unwell and you're not
quite sure why come in get checked out
make sure you're not having a heart
attack cholesterol is bad for your heart
it's all about diet so i'm giving it
right back to you
so there's both good and bad cholesterol
in your bloodstream the good cholesterol
actually helps to clear the bad
cholesterol out of the bloodstream which
is really important that bad cholesterol
the ldl is really the one that is most
linked to people developing plaque in
their arteries that make them end up in
dr shaw's lab needing procedures so that
bad cholesterol optimally in everybody
should be less than 100 and in people
who are at high risk less than 70 and
some would argue that if we can keep our
bad cholesterol even at the level of
about 50 for our whole lives that's how
we really prevent heart disease the most
important way to get your cholesterol
down and to keep it low is through diet
full of vegetables fruits whole grains
legumes
low in saturated fat processed foods
fried foods trans fats focus on that
lowering of your bad cholesterol then on
raising your good and following a
heart-healthy lifestyle overall you only
need cardio for heart health so cardio
is important but most the guidelines now
also recommend things called resistance
training with weights squats or
different kinds of exercises that
provide resistance that can make you
more tone build muscle build bone and
really improve your heart health overall
the american heart association
recommends to try to get your 10 000
steps in a day we also say do about 150
minutes a week of moderate intensity
exercise or 75 minutes of intense
exercise per week not everyone's going
to be running miles and lifting 200
pounds do what you can start slow and
build up ooh i'm too young to worry
about heart disease i've seen patients
in their 30s
having major heart attacks there are a
few risk factors to think about when
you're on the younger side tobacco use
smoking number one and then thinking
about the genetics that may put you at
increased risk of having high
cholesterol or having diabetes and then
unfortunately in our culture there's
just a lot of really really poor
lifestyle sedentary lifestyle we also
have diets that tend to be very very
high in processed foods put those two
things together and that's why we see
both of us such young patients with
disease so it's never too early actually
i think to
see somebody understand your risk and
prevent heart disease heart disease is a
man's problem we should not be thinking
about cardiovascular disease based on
sex assignment at all heart disease
still remains the number one killer of
women but in the 50s and 40s people just
assumed this only happened to men they
used to actually advise
wives on what they can do to keep their
men healthy for their hearts what we do
is we sort of ignore this whole problem
until menopause probably because of the
links to different hormones that
actually protect you during your early
years until you get to menopause and
then all of a sudden it's kind of too
late it's important to get that
awareness out this is everybody's
problem and we all need to be more
aggressive
at screening preventing and treating
heart disease this is a disease that is
largely preventable smoking only affects
the lungs so not the case you know it
damages the endothelium of the heart
muscle of the arteries of the heart and
so that damage allows plaque to be built
up cause a lot of inflammation in the
body which also damages the endothelium
and then that inflammation as well as
the endothelial damage can also allow
blood clots to form if you think about
the biggest artery in the heart you're
lucky if you have one that's four or
five millimeters in diameter but for the
most part it's three millimeters in
diameter so all you need is a little
clot to block off blood flow to that
heart muscle and the good thing is we
have so many ways to help people quit
smoking nowadays we prescribe
medications to help them quit we have
patches we have these groups available
counseling once you quit within 20
minutes to a few days you'll already
start seeing some benefit with the
decrease in blood pressure a decrease in
heart rate within a year your risk will
be down to half of what it would have
been if you had continued smoking but
unfortunately it really takes 10 to 15
years before your risk normalizes to
those who never smoked before yeah still
beneficial and really you'll get there
eventually we want you to know all your
numbers if we recognize your risk at an
early stage we can completely change
your destiny and then sometimes no
matter everything that you do you will
still have a heart attack or stroke
heart failure these are things that we
take very seriously so if you're not
feeling well come on in get checked out